hello I'm gap under and this is the
slowest slow mo guys video we've ever
done
pretty interesting we're gonna spin a CD
literally at warp speed so it's gonna go
so fast around around it's going to
start warping warp one warp one and then
it's gonna break and shatter into a lot
of different pieces the critical spin
rate of a CD is twenty three thousand
rpm hopefully we'll be able to achieve
that and film it at twenty eight
thousand five hundred frames a second
okay we've hooked up the motor from a
Hoover or Dyson or why we call it vacuum
cleaner vacuum cleaner an American so
it's the motor spins really fast we've
hooked up to the mains and and hopefully
it's a Dyson so it does about sort of
like eighty thousand rpm this one so
I'll be able to shatter the CD with this
now small do you think the CD pieces
will be I reckon they're be dust dust
dust yeah does have been dust it's a
little bit of dust
yeah we've hooked it up I've got two
washes here this is a cooler CD and then
bolted it in just going to spin it
around so I'm excited because we're
using a new phantom today this is the V
25:11 and it's the fastest camera we've
ever used at 720p or do twenty eight
thousand five hundred frames a second
and at its lowest resolution we'll do a
million frames a second so we've hooked
up this very AK to the Dyson motor so
that we can vary the speed and the power
go into the motor and then dial up until
it breaks and shatters and see what RPM
we get - okay Dan
I'm slightly scared I'm scared - I don't
know what's gonna happen
okay we got two point six seconds sit
okay I already know it's about to go and
I think it's up there yeah
very good for it I'm running that
[Applause]
startup
though yet
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so it's gonna get to the moon
everybody - I mean - like a hundred
thousand
[Applause]
so as you can see from this 2500 frames
a second isn't nearly fast enough to see
what happened there look what we got
see it whooping look at that Wow moving
so much oh my God look at look at the
shape of it it's moving like the whole
thing wow it's amazing it's just
shutting tiny little bits it's just like
physics don't know what to do in this
fight nope
no I'm good I'm done oh that's amazing
see that again I've seen that lowest
piece I've never seen it so clear what
frame rate was that 28,000 28,000 frames
a second so that looked good it looked
amazing
I never thought I would say the 28,000
frames a second isn't fast enough no no
but when you can go faster you go faster
we did that at 720p I've lowered the
resolution to 768 by 480 giving us a top
frame rate of 62,000 frames my goodness
well I'm not gonna work out now but
that's a lot slower than milk well if we
play back at 25 that's gonna slow a
minute it's gonna slow a second down to
about 40 minutes this yeah we've got
more stuff on the CD this time again for
scientific purposes yeah we've got a
baby face all right Daniel full speed
full speed ahead warp drive on
okay
this is satisfying to turn is it yeah
Oh
[Music]
you can actually see it warping inhale
Inlet in real life that's awesome
I jumped you jump yeah they'll happen
eventually that's the thing when your
frame filming of this many frames a
second you were the actual motor where
something happens it takes forever to
get to oh that was also because you saw
the actual shape of the CV and the
cracks in it were perfectly like the
direction this CD was spinning so
there's my cue spiral effect on the CD
turbine alright so that was at 62,000
frames a second so what's that 40
minutes for one yeah so I've done here
yeah I've lowered the resolution to 384
by 256 very small to do it yeah but
hopefully big enough to see some
shattering framerate that's we go let's
take it up an angel 100 120
170 thousand frames a second so that's
we had basically 62 lost I think it's a
hundred and seventy thousand that's
ridiculous I'm actually getting giddy
just bring the speeds that's not so
excited let's blow it
[Music]
[Applause]
that's ridiculous shot in 96 gigs in
that in
oh look at that that's awesome just the
shape it makes when it shatters like a
little tree wow that is amazing
that's wicked that is amazing it goes
like either side of the middle hole
doesn't it like you're supposed to shape
CG and then finally meets up again at
the other side so now what we're doing
is we've moved the CD rig so the camera
is looking down the edge so we can
hopefully see how much it warps from the
side angle which I think would be
interesting and we'll film this twenty
eight thousand five hundred frames a
second again that's just doing some
final touches to the artwork of the CD
[Music]
like a CD anymore oh that's amazing
it's been it's spinning like a different
speed so it's war that's amazing
the walk just seems to be staying there
while the CD spins further and further
around almost like the air is pushing it
looks like recreate these things trying
to take off that's awesome you can see
why it gives out yeah that is some force
I only thought the warp would have gone
around with the disk you know I mean
yeah mice just exploded then it
pulverized her solid well that was some
incredible footage I have never seen
that that's slow before yeah that's the
fastest thing we've ever filmed and the
Fosters framerate as well
a hundred and seventy thousand frames a
second that's nuts the CD got very small
yeah I like that it was so powerful that
we actually had a spindle of CDs at the
bottom of the device here and it's
crapped through one two CDs one shot CD
ruined all the others and the shot just
went crack straight through the level of
three CDs our lovely clean white
background had an incident at its own
yeah went straight through that it would
push like it's just gone straight
through another couple where I doubt the
CD even noticed
no no well thanks very much for watching
that video be sure to follow us on
Twitter buy a shirt if you want we sell
shirts who are thought and a subscribe
to the slow mo guys cool
you